we will take five random suggestions
from anywhere in this room and then it
will be a freestyle rap so people
shouting over there we will come to you
handsome man
the person someone bellowed something
out well no it wasn't that
[Laughter]
and thank you for putting the
the kabul airport
you made some tables of people over
there very upset
very upset are you afghani women
it was unlikely
airport let's come to this side room and
hope you are not as deviant as these
people
because we need three more suggestions
so if you're over here what would you
like to rap about
you want to hear a love story and with a
voice like that of course
well what i need to know from you is who
would you like or what would you like to
hear a love story about
maybe like in new york
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a
so far these are quite good suggestions
please don't [ __ ] it up over here did
someone say gandalf yeah cool great um
and then one final suggestion come from
anywhere
you're all saying
oh [ __ ] i forgot you've had a hand up
you were so upset because everyone's
bigger
[Music]
like the rest of us right okay
no yeah
to
a new york love story
gandalf
and the guy who has to spray down front
are you excited
this beat drops him real fast so that's
why you you were going
you're just jealous that i haven't
commented on how handsome you are but
you are
so let's um let's uh
let's do this cool
next president a real shitty man he'd be
coming out there spitting on the fake
tan lying down upon the bed got the wig
upon his head well technically it's real
or at least that's what he said he hates
that he's ever so tasty on the skin hate
that he gets the lines on his double
chin and so he tells the man with the
little spray gun saying i'll lift it up
yeah the guy's called trump obviously he
knew he does it every day in his life
getting more orange on the number 45
he's gonna got two hours of fight then
he's got time to hate me about
[Music]
is it the gray or the white what's he
gonna appear as he's there riding right
on the back of shadow facts the name of
his horse you can't stop it he's coming
over there it was shittering the hobbit
then the lord of the rings that was
named the kids but gandalf the balrog
yeah he takes the hits he was going down
there falling i'll tell them don't worry
you'll come back because ian mckellen's
name is there in the credits he'll
possess he'll be right there
dearly missed then he appears right for
the battle for more door you're like yes
gandalf oh yeah more of you please he
comes in riding with the staff people
run away all the orcs they dash they're
like
[Music]
we hate that guy is that a good old
voice of all like for a kid played by
samoan guys down in new zealand i'm in
new york yes it's so appealing if you're
not from here you've come near and far
maybe from a rural country got a truck
for a car you show up here
she's down the street she's like really
trying to run and she bumps into a dude
it's like a neat cute she drops all the
clipboards and one of her shoes the
heels breaks off the healer is snapped
she falls over and then she spies a rat
she's like this is attractive yeah he
won't bore me with his [ __ ] stories yeah
love story you can't ignore these she
picks up the tiny little vermin she says
you're the prince charming
that was so good that's what
[Music]
let me move over there
[Music]
they're
taliban guys if you see this online
please leave me alone i'm really scared
from my life you were in the airport
really ruining the nights people trying
to evacuate gather there and you were
like there's no flights on afghanistan
air but here's one final thing you keep
it clean if there's no schmidt then the
ladies they are keen they're looking
down there they're like so adoring and
that's one advantage to not having a
force
[Applause]
you